this game is not what it seems
there's something sinister going on in
the background but either way
you hear quit
oh
hello
peek-a-boo
anybody there is that how i got in here
radar
i
hate that
okay
so like i said this game is not what it
seems unless i didn't say that in which
case this is the first time i'm saying
that this game is not what it seems i
remember i saw this game on either a
video or something that i was scrolling
through tick tock on i don't remember
quite where it was a while ago that i
got this and then i forgot that this was
in my library and now i'm going to play
it but you're in a maze and that's all
you need to know and there's an
objective and i'm going to try to get to
that this
that
13.
i'm guessing that means there are 13 of
those things left and i got to find them
all
[Music]
hello shut up
well that can't be good
i'm just gonna go with the idea that
that's not good
okay but i got i am right i need to get
all these i see okay i need to get all
the blue glowy things there's a reason
why this game is called it's steals but
i don't remember why i don't remember
what that's about or i don't know what
that pertains to
you can't run well that's very slender
the eight pages which is awfully
coincidental considering i just played
that again
who needs a radar
oh i don't sound good hello
can you shut up in there i'm trying to
play a game
i'm trying to steal some things
trying to avoid some secret darkness
well this doesn't seem too hard and i
always get perturbed when something
doesn't seem too hard
nine
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
what the where white white in the hell
was that what happened
what did you what did you do to me
what
oh my god
what in the freaking hell
are you talking about
what are you doing to me
why would you why would you do that
why would you freaking do that ladder
why would you do that
huh
what would you do why
stop i don't get it i don't get it i
don't understand
i don't know
i don't know
i don't know
that's weird
that's weird ass blood
is that my blood i don't get it
that's bizarre
okay i will
oh my god oh my god i can sprint oh my
god oh my god oh my god yeah i know i
know oh my god you're right about that
holy crap
oh my god running is dangerous you don't
know that
running seemed to save my life so you
can shut up
oh my god
okay so i was not joking when i said
that there was something else about this
game that was weird
something untoward
i didn't like that
i didn't like that at all
i didn't flash it what do you mean flash
it i can't
why
i get angry when you run what do you
mean will you get angry when i run
i'm dead all right let's try this again
shall we
failure is a part of the experience yeah
just like dark souls
okay so it doesn't like it when i run oh
you mean you don't like it when i run
huh you get upset
you're upset spaghetti when i run huh
you don't like this you don't like this
you like a little bit of that
whatever shut up a-hole
or screw you anybody upset that i'm
running
oh god oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay well that um is
unfortunate for me that that is the way
that it is
i don't know if that shows up on my
radar or what or whatever have you
man i'm not okay with that
oh good door
hey whoa hey hey
okay
okay all right all right oh hey whoa
whoa flash it i don't again i i don't
think i can
unless you mean just like move my
flashlight over it which seems to be
working
it has not attacked me and i've kind of
like kept an eye behind me but
i don't know if i just have to
permanently do that now
oh my god i hate that
check the freaking perimeters
there's only four left
okay
so far so good backed into a corner
maybe i could
steal a glance okay all right seems like
there's one off to the right here
first and then i'll circle back to all
those
that are clump
oh no i don't wanna you're not gonna
make me you're not gonna make i'm not
gonna
okay well running is the thing i thought
you didn't like running
i thought you weren't about the running
oh my god i don't know
[Music]
okay yeah that's what i thought
yeah that's what i thought
oh yeah
okay there's one over here not sure what
that thing is but it is a thing
i don't like it
i don't like it at all
why are you so moany
hey
clock sorry if my
rapid extreme pro gamer movements are
oh god i'm a freaking idiot it's a
little difficult aha there it is
oh
whoa
no thank you
wait wait shadow blue blue shadow
am i crazy i'm sorry i'm getting
disoriented what is that about whoa what
is that
what do you mean what happened what
happened did that wall just just
disappear i'm so lost the checker
pattern is just making me
like completely disoriented i don't know
what the blue monster was all about
i i don't understand that
oh my god i'm so wait
that don't look right
that didn't look right at all
wait i hear that
oh god that's not right
that's not rude that's not right
that's not right at all
that ain't right
wait is it called it steals because you
stole them and i gotta find you now is
that what i gotta do
oh no no it's not no it's not i'm just
an idiot
wait a minute that doesn't look right
okay i hear that okay cool
that's three
200. i don't know about that
okay one okay
it's just i saw it oh
that's fine
we
this oh god i thought i was you're i'd
hit no rest bite
all right then
that's only the beginning what is this
i don't know what this is
there is no way out well i mean death
seems to be a competent way out
hello
further in
uh huh
you've not seen the enemy new guide
unlocked
oh what
classic click the oh
watch uh
i don't
mode all five game modes vary in
difficulty from easy to severe if you
want you can unlock all the modes in the
option menu uh shutter mode
what is shutter mode its name is legs
oh
great
oh great
oh this looks good
oh this feels good
no
oh my god
oh i hate shutter mode
oh my god shutter mode can eat my ass i
do not like that
oh
no
no
oh my god i can't
frickin
oh screw this
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh my god okay
is fine
it's totally fine
yeah that's okay
oh my god
oh my god what
stop i don't
oh i do not know where i'm going
oh my god
i guess i should have flashed it i i
don't know all right is there a like a
nope all right cool
i don't need a guide they abandoned the
old labyrinth of course i know how to
play i think
yeah
i wonder why they abandoned the old
labyrinth
couldn't possibly be the nightmarish
leggy creature within
oh i forgot about the running thing oh
ow
you suck i have to stay quiet because i
need to be ready to
snap a picture
oh hate
hate
hate
hate
hate that
hate
that
hate that
freak
my
god
oh i'm running out of batteries oh no
oh no
i'm not nearly where i should be
oh god that's not good that's not good
that's not good
oh god uh dude
is that gonna save me oh no
oh my god
oh
don't touch it
wow a new guide unlock you know what i
think i know how to play flash is scared
away listen for a footstep running
method because it's ruthless when
unranked flashes and i make distance or
it will leap upon you at all costs don't
run out of batteries it knows and we'll
go berserk okay good to know so i gotta
like hurry up
that's what i gotta do i gotta like
hurry
oh my god
that was that was too close
that was what you called too close hurry
up hurry up oh frick okay
the radar makes it seem a lot farther
than it actually is
four left
oh my god oh god this is it okay this is
it this is bad it's bad it's bad it's
bad it's bad
oh my god here we go yup okay make
distance i don't know where i'm going i
don't see any oh yes
oh my god
yeah i got you i got you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay
oh no oh no oh my god i need one more
one more please oh god okay that's over
check my radar
oh my god not near me not near me at all
holy crap okay plenty of batteries left
though
not too shabby
oh my god
one left come on
oh where is it
oh you're kidding
me oh this is the worst
oh there it is
okay it's mine it's mine i win i win i
win i win
i win
oh
[Music]
oh wow
oh look at that i get to keep the
memories
oh
[Music]
great
well
oh what it looks wait i didn't wait no i
know i run the sun's what do you mean
the sunset why i didn't i wasn't ready
to
what run what do you mean run
run what do you mean run
am i supposed to run running's gonna
kill me
what was that
uh
i don't know
am i i i wasn't ready to start up
another game i was trying to bask in the
victory i was
the star was oh
what is god about
oh god
what in the world
[Music]
okay i wasn't ready for that i was
trying to like you know
get better hide and seek okay
you hear quick footsteps sound though
this is different
i'm it am i trying to that means
i need to seek right i'm trying to seek
isn't that it
i'm seeking
if i'm it i'm the seeker
right
i have a bad feeling i'm doing this
holy [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god
i don't know what i'm doing
i don't know what i'm doing
what am i seeing what am i looking at
what is that
oh i'm it you're oh god oh no no no no
no
oh god oh no
oh crap
oh no
i'm doomed aren't i
all right am i doomed
it's just gonna find me
uh
what walls what what about what what huh
what do you mean walls
what about walls what about walls what
do you what do you mean walls
okay so what i need to do is not find it
that's like the earliest objective is
just to not find it because if i find it
i have to run away
so it's like don't find it
okay that that
oh no i didn't know i didn't fall frick
frick frick okay just kill me i this did
not go well
very
okay good i'm sure i understand it when
hiding your flashlight will give you a
way if it's left on crash behind boxes
and shelves listen for the stomping
never run if you stay in one place too
long it will find you when it finds you
it will blast through walls to catch you
make distance don't play along
right okay so just don't find it is that
there's a secret spider i don't know
what that means that's weird
okay never run i'm running
i'm running
okay
[Applause]
well if i'd had just gone the other way
from the beginning i wouldn't have run
into him uh for a long time
oh nope that's him
not going there screw that
i don't know if he moves after i've like
kind of come across him he might
but uh
if he could stay there that'd be great
so far so good
oh god nope not that i saw that
so he does move
he's just trying to get me to find him
i'm not gonna play not playing along
oh frick
nope yeah he's there but i'm not going
to come back
okay
almost there
nine
oh yeah
eight
seven oh frick oh oh god i ran right
into him
all right that was dumb that was really
dumb i panicked and i i don't i did i
panicked i panicked and that didn't go
well
my it might be hard for him harder for
him to be like tagged if my lights off
at a certain point it's like there's
nothing else i can do
that's him
oh frick oh my god are you kidding me
oh frick frick frick frick
all right i'm just gonna try
oh god i'm doomed i'm doomed
wow
oh wow i
oh no
oh god
i'm dead
oh i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead
i'm dead i'm dead i'm
dead i'm dead i'm dead
oh my god no
[Music]
oh frick
okay
okay well that's a little unfair
there i am good for you okay so you
really do gotta just
get those before finding him
if you find him too early you're doomed
okay i've got 12 left
making decent progress
he's definitely got oh that's him
okay
all right
i think this might be the edge of the
map over here if there's a door usually
it i think it means the edge of the map
oh yeah that's him okay none of that
none of that oh my god is this the only
path
yeah i'm not even gonna go that way
i'm gonna go
don't need to go if i don't need to go
i'm not going to go
uh that would be the only way but i
don't need to go
behind me
all around me
this blue light i i swear i saw a blue
light there
oh god oh my god i okay flashlight
didn't matter all right no not gonna not
even gonna not that far away okay so
walls you're light i don't know you hear
quick footsteps i don't hear
okay so light doesn't matter it's just
looking at it for too long that's it
that's pretty much it so don't look at
that down there i see that that is one
but i'll get it later come back for that
oh
well nope
god damn sometimes it's instant
sometimes it's not i gotta be way more
i'm i'm like
i'm taking this too seriously
oh god [ __ ] that
oh
[ __ ] you you were actually hiding why
did i even look over there i don't even
know why i looked i don't even know why
i did
i don't know why i'm trying this i'm 12
away i literally got down to five one
time
without ever hitting him how did i do it
i don't know
i'm dead i'm dead i'm i'm so oh my god
i'm dead
i'm not dead
stunningly i'm not dead but i'm about to
be i'm up i'm dying dead
oh my god
oh my god i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm
dead oh i'm dead
oh my god
oh frick oh frick
oh frick i'm dead
oh god i'm no i'm not no i'm not no i'm
not no i'm not oh god run away
i'm not here i'm not here i'm not here
i'm not here i'm not here i'm here where
oh oh oh you really do smash oh okay
ah
good
good all right i'm gonna get it this
time i'm gonna get it this time this
time i am gonna get it
nope screw that noise i see it
oh what how did you moved already god
damn you
i'm not doing it
oh
oh
goodness gracious
bam boom bam
okay you know it's it's a fairly
generous amount of time once it's like
i've what
what
are you serious
it let's go after a while and then is it
hide and seek again
am i hit am i am i it
i don't hear it anymore
what happened
what
it is that is that's what oh it's i'm in
it's starting again
so you can get away from it i was just
running into a dying assuming that i was
gonna instant die
oh
oh i see you
[Music]
oh god oh wait wait wait [ __ ] i'm way
too far away whoa whoa whoa three two
one
okay
oh [ __ ] so if he does find me i just
need to run away really well
and ideally towards the
things i'm going for oh god
that's stompy
i hear it
frick
oh frick okay here we go
two more
oh god here i go here i go okay
there i am here i am okay making
distance making distance
making distance making distance grabbing
one more one more one left one left
distance distance getting distance oh
god oh god oh my god no not with one
left
oh
oh you saw my uh god damn i had one left
are you kidding me i had one left
oh my god that's infuriating that's
infuriating
oh [ __ ]
don't know how he must be there but he's
probably not going to miss me again
or is he
okay here i am yes
yep here it comes
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
oh boy
oh oh and i got him
okay
there's only like
five or so left a few there's not that
many i just need to not find him
five left
nothing
i see light up there
okay
everyone just hold on why did the light
go out
okay two up there three maybe
okay two to my right
and then something's in front of me oh
yeah
let me get this first
oh frick which do i go for
okay two behind me one in front of me
okay let's try go for these
two left it's those two over there
they're right around the corner
super close
oh my god
oh my god
very close
i'm just going to back into this one
and another one
because he might be there
the other one is literally
down this hall to the right
yeah
and then left
where is it
oh how do i get there
uh no idea
okay there's a path over there
is that's him that's him
is that him
no not him
yeah it's it's on the other side of this
wall
how the hell do i get that okay
he's definitely going to be here
maybe not
oh frick
oh my god oh that is so weird oh my god
it's been fun yeah it's been fun
oh my god i freaking did it okay yeah oh
god
oh hate okay hate hate
hate hate
hate
all right
won't you play i don't know will i that
was great okay so apparently there are
two more and apparently i'm guessing
that if i click on this i see these tiny
stars below it there are other
versions of this hard modes of those
let's play outside
well that can't be too bad yeehee la dee
dee
la
okay so that's all the time i got for
this one this is a very interesting game
very very scary
very creepy kind of fun
uh and there's a lot more to it so link
is in the description if you want me to
play more of this let me know thank you
oh and uh very importantly remember to
check out distractible down in the
description below if you like me bob and
wade having fun and goofing around and
laughing check that out thank you and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
you